hello everyone I'm a longing welcome to
my channel today I am making another
really short video like my recent
cyberpunk one to tell you guys that I am
playing ghost of Tsushima this is it
this is the menu screen dad saw it
really in my face so I thought that once
again I will take questions from you
guys and instead of doing reviews
because they don't do formal reviews for
games anymore
but I will do another Q&A which are
inherently very review style anyway
because they are very much about me
giving my opinions on things it's just
that I let you guys give me the talking
points instead of weighing up what the
talking points are myself very similar
thing is my point so if you have any
questions about this game that you would
like answered at all please leave them
in the comments below and I will go over
all of those when I record my video once
I've finished the game so you guys know
the review embargo is July 14 so reviews
and my Q&A video are allowed to go up on
the 14th of July at 7 a.m. Pacific time
and live streams in Let's Plays same as
the loss of spot to can go up when the
game is first publicly available which
means Auckland New Zealand is the first
time zone in the entire world so the
game is out July 16 at 5 a.m. Pacific
time that matches up with the release
date in Auckland which is midnight July
17 so I will probably like I did for the
loss of his plot to you as well wake up
at 5 a.m. to stream the game from the
very beginning and I think this one's
gonna be fun because I'm playing it in
Japanese right now and I will probably
want my second playthrough to be in
English so I figured that's what I would
do for this dream playthrough so at
least it'll be a really different
experience to me I think
but otherwise there's not anything else
that I am allowed to say just show you
this document or anything like that but
I did want to say because I was pretty
critical of the lost of US embargo that
I feel like this embargo was really fair
I felt like the loss of his pot to imago
had some restrictions that obviously you
won't even allowed to talk about there
was some chunks of the game that you
couldn't talk about it it didn't feel
right to me that reviewers should have
those restrictions I don't feel that way
about the ghosts of Tsushima apocalypse
so good job very excited to get more
time out of this game excited to talk
about it with you guys I'm not allowed
to say anything else at all so yeah just
leave your questions below and I will
get to them when I can alrighty thank
you everyone